buongiorno a tutti oggi voglio parlarvi
di due cose dell'energia e
dell'innovazione l'energia un problema e
l'innovazione alle soluzioni ma perché
l'energia un problema beh l'energia un
problema perché ne usiamo sempre di più
soprattutto negli ultimi due secoli la
crescita è stata esponenziale e
soprattutto perché ci basiamo su quelle
risorse che sono definite fossili cioè
inquinanti e non rinnovabili andranno
presto esaurimento
torniamo indietro e diamo una
definizione di quello che energia
l'energia e la capacità di un corpo di
compiere un lavoro
prendiamo il cibo ed è facile ogni
giorno ci nutriamo e questo ci permette
di compiere il nostro lavoro qualunque
esso sia per le altre possiamo dire che
sono nutrimento per le tecnologie che
compiono un lavoro al posto nostro
senza entrare nello specifico
distinguiamo appunto tra le fossili
limitate e inquinanti e quelle
rinnovabili
tendenzialmente inesauribili e in più
senza alcun danno per l'ambiente
proiettiamoci un po più in là
continuiamo a crescere sempre più
velocemente giusto per darvi un'idea la
popolazione mondiale ogni giorno cresce
i 200mila persone
c'è una nuova padova che appare nel
mondo ogni giorno e sviluppiamo
tecnologia sempre più complesse ad
altissimo fabbisogno energetico che
quindi consumano tantissima energia in
diverse forme e se vogliamo riempire il
quadro i paesi che crescono a livello
demografico più velocemente sono gli
stessi che oggi utilizzano meno energia
e guardando domani probabilmente avranno
lo stesso nostra qualità di vita
mettiamo tutti insieme e abbiamo quello
che chiamiamo il paradigma energetico
usiamo delle risorse naturali come
energia ma una grossa parte va sprecata
o si trasformano inquinamento
e critica siamo sull'orlo del baratro ma
abbiamo ancora una scelta abbiamo
bisogno di soluzioni per invertire la
tendenza e queste soluzioni vengono dall
innovazione parola supera la moda tra
abusata definiamola propriamente dal
punto di vista di chi vende
l'innovazione è un'invenzione che trova
un mercato dal punto di vista di chi
compra cioè il mercato cioè noi insieme
consumatori l'innovazione qualcosa di
meglio
non è solo qualcosa di più o di diverso
perché se non lo compreremo è veramente
qualcosa di meglio
da dove iniziare tranquilli non toccano
a iniziare per fortuna c'è già qualcuno
che ci sta lavorando
abbiamo un paradigma che non funziona
perché non è sostenibile e andiamo verso
un nuovo paradigma ma che non sappiamo
ancora come è fatto intanto abbiamo già
un obiettivo vivere in equilibrio e in
armonia con l'ambiente che ci circonda
però senza rinunciare a nessuna delle
comodita cui siamo abituati anzi
cercando di migliorare la nostra qualità
di vita
questo processo che ci porta al
paradigma vecchio a quello nuovo si
chiama transizione energetica e può già
iniziare anzi è già iniziato se ci
lasciamo dietro le spalle le tecnologie
inquinanti che usano le risorse fossili
e portiamo in primo piano le tecnologie
mature già esistenti come le pale
eoliche o i pannelli fotovoltaici è un
primo passo e nel frattempo gli
innovatori lavorano per noi una startup
italiana kate energy produce elettricità
andando a recuperare i 20 a centinaia di
metri d'altezza 6 800 metri d'altezza
con il vantaggio che questi 20 sono più
forti e più costanti in alto nei cieli
in fondo al mare dove coltiviamo
microalghe da cui tramite processi che
potete vedere riusciamo a stare del
biocombustibile che un giorno forse
andrà la nostra auto
il trasporto è uno dei settori forse più
critici legato storicamente ai derivati
del petrolio ma già oggi e nel mercato
ci sono delle alternative
tesla ha fatto una spagna elettrica
esiste l'ibrido esisterà un giorno a gas
tutte le strade sono aperte anche se
forse possiamo escludere già qualcuno
altro settore su cui si lavora è ridurre
lo spreco
ness il termostato intelligente
recentemente acquistato da google a due
cose primo si ricorda al posto nostro di
spegnere il riscaldamento quando siamo
usciti di casa e secondo quindi riduce
lo spreco ma secondo aumenta anche la
nostra qualità della vita perché
riaccendere riscaldamento prima che noi
arriviamo a casa l'innovazione non si
muove solo a livello di tecnologia come
gli esempi che abbiamo visto adesso si
muove anche a livello il sistema questo
sistema che vedete dietro di me si
chiama power to gas elettricità e gas
mette insieme differenti tecnologie
prendiamo l'esempio delle pale eoliche
che producono elettricità durante la
notte a oggi non la utilizziamo va
sprecata se questa elettricità
la usiamo per alimentare l'elettrolisi
dell'acqua e da un lato facciamo
idrogeno e dall'altro facciamo ossigeno
l'idrogeno un vettore energetico che è
più facile da conservare e anche da
trasportare
stiamo parlando di cosa estremamente
complesse ma l'innovazione non viene
solo da qua 3 ragazzina in africa 14 e
15 anni hanno sviluppato una pila cioè
che riesce a produrre elettricità
partendo da una risorsa difficile da
immaginare
l'urina alfredo in brasile nel 2002 un
meccanico quindi nessuna particolare
informazione ha creato un sistema per
illuminare le baraccopoli delle favelas
senza utilizzare nessun tipo di energia
un buco nel tetto una bottiglia infilata
dentro acquah più candeggina e la
rifrazione fa tutto il resto la
rifrazione della luce del sole e adesso
parliamo d'italia
se il sistema mondiale è in una
situazione critica l'italia è ancora
peggio dovete sapere che la il sistema
energetico italiano si basa su energie
fossili principalmente petrolio e gas ma
che per di più non abbiamo che quindi
siamo obbligati a importare e comprare
dall'estero con una bolletta per noi
consumatori finali tra le più alte di
tutta europa
è urgente io in questo vedo
un'opportunità enorme non solo dobbiamo
salire sul treno dell'innovazione
energetica ma possiamo e dobbiamo
diventare la locomotiva di questo treno
facendo leva su quella che sono le
nostre risorse più importanti il sole il
mare il vento ma soprattutto la
creatività quindi se avete una buona
idea andate là fuori creato un'azienda
chiama della startup perché alla moda
arrivate con un prodotto o un servizio
innovativo
se questa idea non ce l'avete sostenete
chi ce l'ha se non volete fare né una
nell'altro almeno spegnete la luce e
preserviamo insieme il futuro il nostro
futuro che nel patrimonio stupendo che
noi abbiamo se non volete fare nessuna
di queste cose ancora chiunque voi siate
tenete ben in testa che c'è un problema
ambientale energetico grazie